I'm really quite honored to be invited
to talk at yaks first thing I should say
about the Sherpa project is the
principal investigator for this study is
dr. heimer so he's my bonus he's the one
who really kind of mastermind of this
whole study so basically I'm going to
talk to you a little bit about some of
the findings we've had with the Sherpa
project why Sherpa Sherpa stands for
suburban health education research and
Prevention Alliance for a lot of you who
have done studies you spend inordinate
amounts of times trying to come up with
just the right acronym and what we
really were trying to do with this one
it has nothing to do with Nepal Nepal is
it my pal things but we were looking to
try to come up with some kind of a title
for the study that would not be
highlighting injection active injection
drug users as part of it as a way of
showing respect and trying to maintain
the confidentiality of our participants
so today in the talk i'm going to talk
first of all about why we did this study
as robert mention go into detail about
the method and then i'm going to spend a
fair amount of time describing the
sample one of the reasons why i am going
to spend so much time describing the
sample is to our knowledge this is the
largest study of non-urban inject active
injection drug users that is to say not
in treatment there are several studies
out there about suburban drug users and
injectors but they're usually within
already within the treatment setting
this is the first one that they're
active and not in treatment when they
are enrolled and then I'll go into the
primary analysis and conclusions so the
rationale why did we want to do the
sherpa project it has been I also again
have to
give my hats off to dr. heimer it took
him a few tries to get this through and
funded by NIDA ultimately but there were
indications up to you know two decades
ago that first of all we had an aging
cohort of urban economically
disadvantaged primarily minority
injection drug users primarily heroin
users within urban areas there were
already kind of hints from such
databases as the drug treatment
admissions drug related mortality yes
your medical examiner data national
surveys and then der a data from ER you
know response you know the emergency
ambulance services and the ER admissions
that there was drug use injection drug
use opioid use was occurring more and
more frequently out there beyond those
non-urban areas so and as I say at the
end given all these hints dr. hi Mertzes
started quite a while back on trying to
get a study really to take a closer look
at who are these people what are their
risks what do we need to do for them do
we need to do differently for them than
what we've already done a lot in terms
of HIV prevention and HCV prevention in
urban areas the interventions that have
been developed for those the primarily
for those areas so the specific aims of
this study are for first to assemble and
follow a core cohort of active injectors
in southwestern Connecticut we are
limiting ourselves and we'll get to a
map later on to the counties of fear
field and New Haven we're going to
collect quantitative data on socio
demographic information as you know and
we will collect this quantitative data
longitudinally
and then we're going to test the
hypotheses about influences of the
environmental context on HIV knowledge
injection practices that's both risk and
hygiene hygienic practices and your
knowledge and also zero prevalence of
HIV HPV and HCV HIV everybody I think
probably would know hcv is hepatitis C
and H hbv is hepatitis B if you do if i
use something some terminology that you
don't know please let me know
immediately and i'll address it and then
the fourth aim is to determine the
behavioral patterns that are durable and
identify the factors that modulate the
risk of infection of HIV and the other
viruses over time i will not be going
into that fourth aim we are still in the
process of cleaning and analyzing the
longitudinal data so i will only be
reporting on the baseline data today so
as far as the research messes we methods
we've kind of already I've already
hinted at it this is a multiple methods
longitudinal design we administer a
quantitative interview every six months
starting a baseline the quantitative
interview is both face-to-face and a
Cathy a cassie is a computer-assisted
self interview where we sit the
participant down with a laptop and they
fill it in themselves rather than doing
it face-to-face with somebody we draw a
blood sample at baseline and then every
year annually and do our own testing for
HIV Hep B and Hep C in our labs we had a
subsample of 43 participants that we
recruited over the entire enrollment
period where we really wanted to look in
a qualitative manner and hence the
multiple methods approach at the to try
to get at the more gray areas of how
one's injection drug use
affected employment social interactions
with friends and family education
different kind of income different kinds
of factors involvement with substance
abuse treatment involvement with the
criminal justice system so we had this
subsample of 43 where we did these
in-depth interviews the way they worked
is we had two sessions per person and
those two sessions occurred within no
more than two weeks apart and both
sessions were about four excuse me about
two hours so we had a total of four
hours a lot of qualitative data there
for the qualitative research was out
there we stratified as i said we
enrolled over the entire enrollment in
period we enrolled into this sub study
but we also stratified by sex age and
county of residence recall we have
fairfield and new haven county so um
this may be a little bit out of order
but here it is these are the two
counties Fairfield in New Haven and we
excluded six cities danbury's Stamford
Norwalk Bridgeport New Haven and water
Barry were excluded from our study we
considered those to be large cities
those were urban areas so we were only
recruiting from suburban towns of
Fairfield and new haven county so those
six were excluded the recruitment
strategy was responding driven sampling
um how many people are aware of this
method do I need to go into it it's
about half alright so I'll give you a
real short description respondent driven
sampling is a snowball sampling strategy
that relies upon dual remuneration kind
of system where you recruit somebody
called the seed and you provide them
with a certain number of coupons in our
case we provided them with up to force
with for coupons and
and instructed them to go out and
recruit people that they thought would
fulfill the the inclusion criteria to be
successfully enrolled into our study if
they were if that person that they gave
a coupon to contacted us and then was
successfully enrolled we would then
provide an incentive back to the person
the recruiter that seed would get ten
dollars for every successful recruitment
and that's basically what respondent
driven sampling is about the how it's
touted whether the the good parts to
respond to driven sampling are twofold
first of all it's a very good way of
going into a community that you may not
know and recruiting a lot of people in a
relatively short time rather than go by
going the original traditional outreach
method in a study that we did in Maine
several years ago we were able in one
summer we were able to recruit well over
200 people into a study that that we
were not familiar with the people or the
community we were able to get in via the
respondent driven sampling we were able
to recruit and enroll in a very
efficient way the other good thing to
respond to driven sampling is if it's
done if it if it works the way it's
supposed to work there are calculations
that you apply to the data that are able
to you're able to calculate population
estimates so the bad news for us is we
didn't achieve that we did not have
enough productive chains because what
happens is the first person recruits
some people those people are then given
coupons they recruit more people and you
get these chains of people we never got
to that a sufficient level I think fifty
six percent of our chains of our our
seeds were non productive and so we were
not able to calculate population
estimates this has to be considered
a convenience sample only so inclusion
criteria were you have to be at least 18
you have to have resided in one of the
town's excluding those six cities in
southwestern Connecticut in the 22
counties the way we establish this was
you needed to bring a photo ID and you
needed to bring a piece of mail with
your name and the address from one of
those towns and that's how we establish
residence in one of the suburban towns
you had to have reported that you
injected at least once in the last 50
days we try to confirm this by either
observation of injection stigmata
sometimes that was not you were not able
to do that in which cases we would have
our field staff would have a more
protracted conversation with the person
about their last injection experience to
try in the process and what they went
through to try to get and do they really
seem like they're in ejector or are they
just kind of melding yeah I injected X
I'm sorry the recruitment period as
noted is from november two thousand
eight until january 2012 and you know
there we followed everybody
longitudinally for as long as the study
went on so it was a little bit different
not everybody was recruited at the same
time so not everybody had as many follow
up with interviews so the types of data
collected first of all Sochi of
demographics on the usual suspects age
sex you know race ethnicity educational
level income we broke down into both
legal sources of income as well as extra
legal and perhaps gifts from other
people in the last 30 days benefits for
the most part the benefits were really
what we really were interested in was
your health benefits and living
situation for the health history we
started out by saying in general how we
compared to other people of your age how
would you rate your your your health and
basically it was on a 5-point likert
poor to excellent then we asked about
self-reported HIV HIV Hep B and Hep C
states the way we constructed that was
we said have you ever been tested if so
did you receive result the way we said
it was like something did a medical
healthcare provider tell you that you
were infected so that's the
self-reported you know of positive state
a status for either Hep B Hep C or HIV
and then we had self-report of overdose
experiences and also witness clinical
measures that we included in our rather
extensive quantitative interview
included the addiction severity which is
very commonly used in drug treatment
centers to monitor on several different
domains including legal problems
psychological problems medical problems
your problems with drinking problems
with drugs problems with family we use
the audit see which is a screen for
problematic drinking brief pain
inventory is another measure that is
routinely used in pain clinics we chose
to and we have used it in many of our
studies on the assumption and what we
hear often times that a lot of people
become addicted because of a trauma a
physical trauma where they were
prescribed opioids as pain management
and then it went on to become a more
serious addiction problem so we monitor
pain in terms of the severity of the
pain and how much does it interfere with
your daily functioning and then we had
two screens their brief screens for
depression and anxiety finally we had a
12-item social support scale to try to
get a measure a quantitative measure of
course we went into it a little bit you
know in more detail in the qualitative
studies but we got from all participants
we got at least this brief kind of
estimate of rating your social support
serologic data this is us doing our own
testing we tested for HIV and Hep C that
they're all by Eliza appscene and HIV
it's positive negative for hep b we did
core and surface antibody as well as
surface antigen so that were three tests
for heavy other kinds of self-reported
data included on the injection risk in
hygiene behaviors access to syringes to
clean syringes or two syringes in
general knowledge of hepatitis HIV and
overdose we've used this on several of
our previous studies it's an adaptation
from an HIV now it's a survey that was
done I think in the 80s but at any rate
we've been using it routinely a history
of substance abuse treatment and history
of involvement with the criminal justice
system we also collected geospatial data
the most important three most important
variables for us to consider here is you
know what is your current residence and
then where did you purchase drugs most
often in the last six months and where
did you inject most often in the last
six months and we really took this down
to the town level we do have it below
that but for purposes of this
presentation it's really only by town
and then as I was saying there's the
qualitative in-depth interviews where we
assessed for 12 domains and we're still
in a process of analyzing that data as
well so I'm going to drive this home a
couple times for you I want you to make
sure that you understand everybody all
462 people reside in the suburbs and the
two groups that we compare are those
people who inject most often in urban
areas versus those people who inject
most often in the last six months in
suburban areas so I'm going to talk
about I probably will talk about urban
and
suburban groups-- but you have to
understand everybody's from the suburbs
this is just how we've divided our
Suburbans further all right and I will
repeat this again so going on to the
results as I said since this is really
the first study large study of suburban
injectors I really think that it's worth
our while to spend a little time saying
what are these guys look like so um I
think I skipped alright so the first
thing is age um and this is kind of
going on when I know from previous
studies that we've done in urban areas
mean age mean and median there about mid
30s it's a little bit younger than what
I expect in the urge urban studies that
we've done in the past they're probably
early 40s so they're a bit younger I
think that it's also of interest in of
note that they have been injecting for a
mean of 11 years so these guys were
starting in their early to mid-20s on
injection drug use most likely they were
using opioids for at least two to four
years before they started injecting I
would say the breakdown on on gender is
not unsurprising generally I expect to
see anywhere from two-thirds to
three-quarters or males so this is a
little bit more female representation
but not really enough to for me to make
a big thing of it I think it's also not
surprising this is predominantly a white
population this is Connecticut this is
Southwest Connecticut this is the
suburbs I think most of our minority in
the state of Connecticut are in the
larger cities very there this is legal
marital status they've never been
married this says nothing about and you
shouldn't conflate legal Merrill marital
status with living situation they may be
living with
buddy but the majority have never been
married now yes we did but I didn't look
at that it didn't look at that I haven't
looked at anything this I'm not even
sure if we did I think we did but I'm
not sure this is a study of injection
drug use we have kept but consciously we
have kept all sexual risk associated
with HIV to them in a minimum this is a
long quantitative survey as it was and
we really wanted to focus on injection
wrist so I'm not sure I'd be glad to get
back to you yeah education most of them
had at least a high school education I
think this is a little bit higher than
what I would expect to generally see so
there seemed to be I don't want to say
well educated but they do seem to have
at least high school education and yet
when you look at their income they're
really quite low and then to make the
scene even more I don't know sad only
about thirty percent are currently
employed of those people that are
currently ployed only about half of them
are employed full-time and then by the
time you get down to do they receive
employee benefits virtually nobody get
receives you know employee benefits I
mean so I think that the economic
disadvantage is is still pretty evident
when you look at these descriptive
statistics somehow it's not going
okay i'm not able to move it to escape
yeah it's not it's not
okay well I'll talk while Pete fixes
since we're still just describing this
is this is pretty cool I would say
generally two-thirds of the people live
with family or friends only about twenty
percent twenty-nine percent of them rent
or own their own resident and very few
of them very few of them have served
about seven percent have served in
military service as far as criminal
justice system this is one that I
actually really would like to show the
slide for the the really astounding
thing was that almost ninety percent
eighty nine point eight reported that
they had ever been arrested so these
guys have a lot of involvement with the
criminal justice system so now i'm going
to cascade until p can get us set up so
eighty-nine percent ninety percent
really are ever arrested when asked of
those people how many of you were jailed
thank you very much thanks so of those
people eighty percent were jailed now
that that figure there is holding cell
you know jailed for longer than that or
an overnight lockup but eighty percent
of them were ever jailed sixty-eight
percent of them were convicted but if
you were convicted chances were really
very likely that if you got to the level
of conviction you were going to get
sentenced now the number of times that
they were arrested was nine I thought
what was interesting there you know
average number of times that they were
arrested was nine about a third of those
were on drug violations so they're
getting in trouble I can't say that
those others were not drug related but
at least a third of them were drug
violations for the number of
incarceration the last figure that I
give
that is excluding holding cell and lock
up so those are true incarceration where
they're spending some time in jail got
about an average of almost four times
per you know that they get locked up so
their involvement is pretty high health
status I like this I always say that the
world is broken up into a third a third
a third and basically in this case it is
a third a third a third it's only about
a third that say yeah I really feel like
I just have awful health most of them
are saying yeah I'm pretty good or
excellent what was very surprising he
was how well insured they were now
remember back to our employment staffs
most of these people are on Medicaid
Medicare disability they're on something
most of them are getting their health
insurance through some kind of
government subsidized very few of them
are getting private insurance eight
point seven percent said that they had
private insurance but they are
relatively well insured from a
perspective of health insurance so for
our serial prevalence these were our
tests about one person one almost to a
little lesson two percent or HIV
positive most of them were aware that
was the the self-report part the the
left-hand side is our lab data those are
our self report when we talk about a Hep
C positive about forty percent forty-one
percent of them were have see positive I
guess this is good news bad news it's
pretty high but compared to like well
actually compared to a have vaccine
study that we did where we screened for
hepatitis ten years ago Hartford and
Bridgeport their serial prevalence was
around eighty percent and in injection
drug users it does tend to be higher so
it's high but it's not as high as it
could be I think that's the take home
message format
for a happy positive I kind of want to
explain a little bit the happy positive
what that really is saying is because I
don't know if you know but most people
will clear Hep B so you get infected and
ninety-five percent will clear it
they'll be done my happy positive 20
4.4% there includes people you know that
were previously infected or no are no
longer infected it includes carriers who
are you know currently acute or carriers
currently infected and then this murky
no man's land where they test positive
for core antibody only and we don't
really quite know we assume that they
were infected but they're not showing
the normal serological evidence that
they were infected we assume that
they've been infected the 4.5 you know a
cuter or chronic is about right um loves
concern now remember this is this is a
young group of people and so ok I'm
going to give you a little my history
here so mandating for hep b vaccination
I don't think started until the 90s but
my kids in the early 80s we're getting
vaccinated for hep b it was already I
think fairly routine in most places to
have your kid vaccinated for hep b the
fact that 44.4 percent and you also have
to think this is not an immigrant
population for the most part most of
these people are not coming from other
countries these are Americans and for
forty four percent of them still to be
at risk for infection it's pretty
impressive to me as far as about thirty
one percent of them were already in
vaccinated it didn't put that up there
but it's i can give you that as far as
substance abuse to history these guys
have done it about 70 you know eight
percent of them have ever been in
treatment it's less it's now
that surprising you know the nature of
substance abuse disorder is relapse is
part of the disease so you go in you go
out you go in you go out so the fact
that only about half of them were in
treatment in the last said that they
were in treatment in the last six months
you know is is not surprising as far as
injection behaviors about ninety percent
of them said that heroin was their drug
of choice almost three-quarters seventy
percent two-thirds whatever bought their
drugs in urban locations however almost
sixty percent of them went home to their
own residents to inject you know in the
past 30 days when we asked how you know
where you went so they're buying in the
cities but many of them are coming home
to inject as far as syringe access we it
made sense to us in retrospect very few
of them only three point five percent
use syringe exchange now you have to
think about you know the two counties
the two syringe exchanges are Bridgeport
and New Haven that being said it's a
hell of a schlep for a lot of people to
get to the S EP so going to a local
pharmacy it's not surprising that you
know three quarters of them are getting
their their syringes from pharmacies
rather than syringe exchanges the sad
part about that is you know people who
do go to work syringe exchanges get much
more than just syringes and supplies
they get information they you know
people talk to them about harm reduction
they get referred to you know substance
abuse treatment these people are not
getting that I would think all right
about a third of them said that they
have experienced overdose the median
number of times that they had personally
experienced overdoses was to almost
seventy percent said that they had heard
of narcan
arcane is I don't know how many of you
particularly now that Hoffman you know
died narcan is what is used to reverse
opioid overdoses but this is not this is
pre Hoffman but I think there's much
more in in the media right now about
narcan as a result but there were fairly
aware about it as far as injection risk
behaviors I want to kind of point out a
few things the number of injections for
the last 30 days mean number of
injections is 70 times I expect most
kind of firmly ensconced injection drug
users to be using daily three to four
times so I am NOT surprised I kind of
expect for the if you ask them how many
times in the last 30 days I expect to
see something in the 90 to 120 range so
these people are not injecting quite as
much um shots per syringe I think that's
fairly fairly anticipated from our urban
studies that's about what I expect to
see now we asked about all sorts of
injection risk behaviors we pulled them
the bolded one engaged in any of the
following is a pooled figure and it is
kind of concern that over half of them
engaged in at least one of those risk
behaviors at least once in the last 30
days so the risk is not inconsequential
I think that a couple things for me to
point out to you is first of all Steve
kester an ethnographer in Colorado has
done a lot of work where he had gone out
in the field and observed injections and
he has found that when people split
drugs either in dry or liquid form
certainly much more in liquid form what
generally tends to happen is somewhere
along the line there is a breach in
injection hygiene so even though the
people who are splitting the drugs
really think that they're keeping
everything
safe and separate in actuality when you
have that third Observer that
ethnographer in the room with them that
isn't the case so we added in those
questions to really look and see at
splitting and splitting you know in dry
form is certainly over half of them are
splitting in dry form but you know
everyone in fun one in five are
splitting in liquid form which i think
is a far more risky the other things
that are of concern to me are sharing of
water both the drug mixing water and the
rest risk water I think this is a very
good opportunity for particularly Hep C
infection and then of course sharing
syringes that that is there to as a
concern all right so here I am ramming
it down your throat one more time before
I go into the primary analyses everybody
is from the suburbs what we're doing is
splitting into those who inject most
often in the last six months in urban
areas versus those who inject most often
in the last six months in suburban areas
all right so our first hypothesis was
that our suburban injectors and so I've
now started to use urban and suburban
groups-- okay or saying that they have
perhaps a less stressful lifestyle hmm
this is not this is not what I wanted to
show you
oh yes it is I'm sorry oh sorry so with
our bivariate analyses the only thing
that we really found out was that our
suburban injectors tend to more to be
more likely to have health insurance
they also tended to be older and I guess
as you know kind of co varying with that
is if they're older they probably have
been injecting for a longer period of
time than your urban's but really
essentially for the by and large these
guys didn't change it didn't differ to
substantially from each other sex race
religion employment income you know
encounters with CJ system number of
partners basically their equivalent ok
so for hypothesis to basically what
we're saying there is that your suburban
injectors would have whiskey ER behavior
our reason for this and I've already
hinted at it is they're not getting to
those harm reduction programs that are
probably more prevalent in urban
locations they're not going to get their
syringes from these places so they're
just not going to know as much and
they're probably going to engage in in
riskier behaviors what we found when we
did that was actually the urban people
that we thought we're going to be safer
injectors because they are exposed we're
actually the ones that were riskier
thinking about it however we were
thinking these guys all live in the
suburbs the people who are injecting
most often in urban areas may not have
all the amenities that they may have at
home they may be hiding from friends and
family that they inject so they're
they're choosing to inject in other
places they're injecting in you know
galleries of shooting galleries public
places parking lots hallways they may
not have all those things and so because
of lack of you know appropriate kinds of
equipment for
safely they are engaging in risky
behavior the other thing that we found
was females tend to be at higher risk
for engaging in risky action associated
risk behaviors I think that that has
been shown in other studies as well we
can talk a little bit more about that
later on a third hypothesis is that the
servants would be less the suburban
injectors would be less knowledgeable
again because they're not exposed
they're just going to be less
knowledgeable what we found there was
again no difference in knowledge between
whether you inject most frequently in
urban areas or suburban area they were
equivalent however being white having at
least a high school education or more
than six partners were associated with
you having higher knowledge and we hear
it's a combined HIV hepatitis and
overdose no it's that we're assessing so
those those three factors really really
were associated with better knowledge I
look at these and say that probably this
is actually going back to an old study
from dr. Reimer where he was looking at
diffusion of benefits this was in the
beginning of syrah on the hypothesis
that said that information harm
reduction information would bet you
diffuse from syringe exchange programs
to people who use syringe exchange
programs to their friends who may not
necessarily use exchange programs but
they're just talking and injecting
together or hanging out together and so
they'll they'll give you information
that they learn from their there from
the syringe exchange here I think having
more partners you probably are more
likely to talk about I would think that
this could be one way to attend you're
just talking and so you're learning
you're gaining from your colleagues
gaining knowledge about HIV hepatitis
and overdose on the downside to this
okay to downsides
first of all true false kinds of
questions and this is a true/false
question tend to overestimate knowledge
I don't want to go into it just accept
what I'm telling you it's an over
estimate of knowledge the average
overall knowledge score was fifty-nine
percent so I'm saying these guys are
probably not much better than chance at
answering these questions their
knowledge they may be more knowledgeable
but they're not all that knowledgeable
even in the best of situations there
were some people that got ninety percent
but I just wanted to put this kind of in
context for you all right last
hypothesis we hypothesized that the
Suburbans would have lower cero
prevalence so this makes no sense to us
because what I've said is we expected
the Suburbans to be riskier we explore
expected our Suburbans to be less
knowledgeable but now I'm saying we're
expecting our Suburbans to have lower
zero prevalence how can that be it's
because this is a younger we're we're
less far along in the epidemic this is a
relatively new this being injection drug
use and heroin use is relatively young
in the suburbs so that the bringing of
disease will lag a little behind the you
know wave of the problem of opioid use
and injection drug use so that's why we
said that we thought that they were
going to have lower zero prevalence I
hope that makes sense to everyone what
we found actually okay let me go back
here we found no difference for HB HB v
or hcv we couldn't test for HIV you
remember we only had seven no way to
compare
so but we found that there was no
difference in Sura problems between the
two groups we went to co-infection since
we really could not do anything we
looked at co-infections so what I'm
going to report here is actually not
quite what we hypothesize but this is
what we found we found that again having
at least a high school education was
protective of being co-infected
co-infection here define is having two
of any of the three okay the other thing
was the longer you had been injecting
the more likely you were to become
infected I think this is something that
makes a lot of sense to most of us it
was not surprising okay so conclusions
first of all we can characterize a
sample is basically being white young
single and most of them having completed
the least a high school education
whether you want to call that well
educated or not is up to you of concern
to us however is the low eckin the high
unemployment the frequent interactions
with the CJ system and the injection
risk behaviors I want to talk a little
bit more from our qualitative data it is
a huge problem and a big concern to our
participants lack of money trying to
find a job can't find a job the whole
financial disadvantage of these people
is right there in our faces practically
on a daily basis in our interviews and
our in-depth interviews the frequent
interaction with the CJ system the bad
news I guess is that you don't see
living in the suburbs doesn't seem to
protect you very much from involvement
with the CJ system the it's a
double-edged sword in that
again mostly from the qualitative data a
lot of times this enables you to get
into treatment either for two reasons
either you're seeking to mitigate your
you know charges or sentencing so you go
because of your CJ problems or you go
you know to drug court or and your
sentence to do treatment so criminal
justice can can also be seen in some way
as a harm reduction effort in that they
do get a lot of people into treatment
again for the injection associated risk
we really need to work on don't share
don't split drugs if you are let's talk
about how you're doing it there are ways
to protect make it safer don't share
water and don't share syringes for the
most part as far as injection risk
behaviors as I said we found but I've
also explained we were surprised that we
were seeing that it was the urban's who
were more likely to engage in it but I
think that's because they don't have the
amenities of home we need to do things
for females I think that there are
things that are inherent in the
injection process these are very
consistent with other studies done over
time in many regions on that the
dynamics of the injection environment
oftentimes puts the female at a
disadvantage I'm not prepared to tell
you today how we can work with this all
I can tell you is this is something that
seemed consistency and needs to be
addressed either we need to have to
understand better what we can or cannot
do and then design interventions as far
as the knowledge we saw that you know
people to talk to each other about an
hour's and that's good co-infection we
would
not surprising to us that the longer
you've been injecting the more likely
you are to be co-infected this whole
thing of level of education perhaps the
people who made it through high school
we're getting some kind of you know in
their health class they were getting
some of this knowledge that other people
weren't getting and so they were
protecting themselves from co-infection
I don't know but I do know that my
take-home message from here is we really
need to start thinking about innovative
technologies and innovative venues for
getting the word out one of the
innovative venues that I would suggest
is pharmacies that you know we should be
making better use of pharmacies for
people who just may have missed out of
it you know out earlier in life and in
conclusion the limitations first of all
this is not a probability I told you
this is a convenience sample so we have
limited generalizability the other thing
and I think you can say this about most
if not all RDS studies is that you are
not getting those upper income people
let us face it if I am sitting there in
cos cob or Greenwich you know with my
six figure income and my wife and my two
point three kids there probably is no
amount of money or any kind of incentive
you can offer me to make me want to be
part of your study okay then
self-reported data we all know this one
that recall bias
we we did what we could in terms of
programming much of it to be in a Cassie
to try to get more valid estimates the
biggest limitation to our study is that
we do not have an urban IDU group and
that to get to defensive but when dr.
heimer went to NIH with this application
there was in the research design a
comparison group of urban injectors the
review committee in its infinite wisdom
decided to fund this project however
remove the the urban comparison group
and this is truly you know the fact that
we're not seeing more differences these
guys are all basically suburban guys so
I'm sorry about that but you know it is
what it was I'd like to also thank NIDA
first of all for funding this dr. heimer
was the p.i especially all our
participants and the research staff
particularly community health service in
strafford was a methadone clinic that we
used that was very helpful in terms of
providing us we got people as they were
entering methadone but they had been
using within the previous 30 days and
they provided a place for us to go and
an interview down there which was quite
lovely wilson palacios has also helped
us with the qualitative data amisha who
has left did all our blood work she was
beyond fantastic and we have some great
Chris hennigan I don't know if Lisa's
here lisa is here
they were fabulous out in the in the
field and that's it thank you